foreign
[Music]
I didn't yell at my children before we
started today you guys welcome back to
the break room Our Daily Show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy nose that
you need to know about uh coming up
today we're going to be talking about
the acolyte which I don't know what that
is uh movies are moving you guys movies
are coming they're moving they're going
I don't know which way they're going up
down sideways inside out my favorite
film Disney plus is slipping up is
slipping up you guys they're making a
lot of messes and we are there to eat up
all the pieces HBO cancels one of its
most popular shows and one of their most
Emmy award-winning shows and also we're
gonna get Quentin Tarantino which sounds
dangerous and yeah
good thing my nails are long like Talent
you guys yes absolutely on my feet today
we're here with Anna hi
hi for Brandon's bat sounds here's my
impression
that wasn't one of ten uh I think it was
an 11. yep Jessica who cares here are
Tommy Vector great to be here gang so
happy to be here have a great Friday
someone possessed him
last but not least oh I'll take off
camera four I'm the smile boy from the
movie smile
that marketing campaign I've heard so
much about uh questions here yeah yeah
who knows what camera I'm just afraid
it's always going to be Question Master
time when certain people are here so I'm
afraid it's quiz master I don't give the
title it's respect because I fear the
wielder I'm sure that won't put you in
there good graces but I don't know for
sure Brandon 6.5 what is it an extremely
warm room come on let's go also for
April said Tommy is a scroll and I would
absolutely say he is from that
um you guys are Redemption oh God our
Redemption today is if we break 200
we'll spend some extra time talking to
you about anything yeah so go ahead and
send in those super chats of everything
you guys want to know we'll do a little
AMA for y'all after the show is over to
an extent I don't read Jessica said she
will answer any question I never said
that yeah Jessica promised if there's
any thing that you want to know about
Star Wars stuff you're president of the
Star Wars fan club is here to answer
your questions guys look we're here ask
Anna anything about Star Wars and then
Coy and I will happily tell you about
our tattoos yeah oh what is koi I don't
have attention
I'm tattooing koi's face later
as part of our uh uh destroy your life
November uh what's the tattoo headlines
no regrets November
November
okay Daphne Keane joined Star Wars
acolyte um if you know the acolyte I
don't
um do you mind telling me what the
Angeline is the acolyte is a show based
in the Star Wars universe that takes
place thousands of years before the
events of the Skywalker Trilogy uh
exploring an old and ancient religion
not much is known about the plot of the
story but we do know that the show is in
development and there has been some
casting news so we're pretty excited
about that oh my God I think one of the
guys from squid games has been casting
it oh they have yes they have also uh
Daphne Keane is x23 and Logan the little
girl there she is not as little as she
once was fresh blood for the Hollywood
Machine
all right
please just activate
no but really someone in Florida that
like runs a q Anon blog just was like
now I'm listening yeah we just put on so
many lists I guess
now like wait a second are they talking
about the truth
but do you root for like whenever I know
she was in Logan but she is considered
in Hollywood like a fresh face and I
always worry for like Fresh Faces making
it into these things
I root for hanger faces Haggard face
Friday
the old leathery ones listen some of us
have been in this town a long time
waiting for our big break
I know he wants to be the next Daphne
Keith all right take the camera floor
real quick take the camera forward real
quick to the floor
is that old leathery face no it's not I
just want to see that in movies all of
that geology made him look like a fresh
baby I want to be a star oh my God next
headline speaking of stars the dungeon
and Dragons movie release just got moved
from March 3rd to March 31st 2023 Scream
Six also got moved from March 10th uh to
March 10th 2023 so soon that's like yeah
we're legit getting scream in like five
months yeah and it's not like it's just
didn't we just scream the
my ex-wife told me it's bad if you
scream more than once every six months
I'm sorry
um
the fact that scream 6 got priority over
the Dungeons and Dragons
like the San Diego Comic-Con they had
that cool castle like the trailer
looking people had a tough time I feel
like latching on to Dungeons and Dragons
material outside of the RPG game I feel
like anytime they make a movie or like
say any sort of like straight to TV
thing which they did a little more in
the 80s and 90s your youngsters uh
people are like no just play the game ah
thanks thanks Bucky thanks Joe I feel
like people like Dungeons and Dragons
but when they're together confusing
any uh d d podcast or anything yeah I
don't listen to podcasts there's too
many of them I don't watch YouTube
either I think it's a boring meeting
I work for D20 uh
uh Shameless
plugins
you want to do it again no no no clean
get it clean I don't think so I don't
know I think you should go here before
uh no no I'm joking I'm joking I work
for Deez Nuts
[Music]
clip it put it on the internet
oh my gosh another headline headline
layers it's not clean
headline number 12. Andy Circus doesn't
think we've seen enough snoke wow that's
convenient for him
I think we should put back to the screen
my character that's actually the quote
that he said yes
he said I would love to know first of
all I would love uh I would love him to
think about further snoke actually I
think I would say to him look I don't
think we've seen enough snoke I think
people would love to see more snoke and
really fills his lore behind snow
because I think there's so much fertile
ground that is yet to be covered so I
think that's why I try to get out of it
we're gonna get paid in Smoke yeah
he's on another Star Wars show right now
sorry Anna what were you gonna say well
I'll just I'll be convinced if he can
slip snoke in a few more times
more than a thirsty thespian that's not
a man that's a man on the verge of
absolutely dying of of thirst I think it
goes beyond a symbol do we have the
graphic
the Thirsty thespian graphic no oh
yes
thank you
dashlaw on the controls today so you
know the show's gonna be toy toes that's
who's sucking up The Souls of the young
it's those puppets Jesus Anna no one is
sucking any Souls of the young okay well
break room is gonna go on record here
yeah you can read Anna's blog we'll run
news max but over but here we're gonna
keep the souls of the young fresh okay
we're gonna keep him safe and sound uh
all the young Souls will be safe and
sound on our watch next headline okay
Disney plus slipped up and leaked its
baby Yoda short you guys grogu and the
dust bunnies debuts on Disney plus
November 12th Disney Italy uh Disney
plus Italy tweeted it and immediately
shut up
I just want the idea of like Disney
being like Disney plus Italy you're on
thin ice we're gonna take Pinocchio off
we're gonna take took off all of your
hits will be gone these are all leaving
you can say arrivederci
is that that was Italian
Bongiorno all I know in Italian is which
I think is an f word oh we're gonna get
the demonetized yeah now we're gonna get
demonetized before 3 30. but uh Disney
plus Italy tweeted it out and
immediately deleted it but not before
Reddit could get a hold of it
um which seems like this goes for
celebrities too don't tweet things out
that you want delete it because unless
you're actively doing it on purpose
because people are gonna find those
tweets I'm talking to you cardi B and
Drake because they post things cardi B
got very drunk might get demons got very
drunk I posted like a selfie but her
left boobs
she said it doesn't she said it doesn't
matter she was like I don't even care
and I was like I love that first God
bless do we think this is gonna be like
uh something like these animations
Disney's animations that they put out
which is just like kind of extra footage
a tribute to the to the animators or is
this gonna be like a full extra short
new like like root I feel like it's
gonna be like Groot right like there was
that like six episodes of group that
were like three minutes oh yeah adorable
I feel like it's like that but also
maybe this is Mark marketing for we're
talking about it maybe Disney plus was
like put it on Italy yeah because
November 12th unless we're talking about
next November 12th and soon that's next
week eight days from Friday it's good
marketing we're talking about it
I'm gonna I'm gonna devour this uh I'm
gonna watch it completely four times
through because grogu is my number one
person I I can't wait to watch a little
grogu film just the two days after my
birthday
22. I can't wait to turn 19. fresh-faced
Hollywood new star going straight to
Canada to drink my first beer Soul
suckers get ready
I'm just picturing like the mentors and
suits and like agencies is how you see
Hollywood yeah we want you to play a
Twilight vampire
forever I don't like
joker I'm sucking things uh Disney one
more just one more tuck it in my pocket
okay one more time
uh Disney plus is Daredevil has a new
fun working title The Working title is
now for born again will be filming under
out of the kitchen can't stand the heat
can't stand that heat out of the kitchen
so I got a couple theories one maybe
he's not New York that way they mix it
up or it starts on the west coast
because
or is this like uh more of a this isn't
your father's Daredevil kind of
statement like we're out of the kitchen
we're breaking things you know I mean it
could be that kind of statement also it
could be literally like the the DU hot
like so those are the three ways I think
this plays around with
tiny just being like yeah you know what
we're just gonna kick him out of the
East Coast right you come out of the
East Coast you know what Daredevil's not
synonymous with Hell's Kitchen get rid
of him I know exactly it's like the guy
that's most associated it would make
more sense if it was like a chapter of
the uh episodes if it was one of the
like one of them was out of the kitchen
it was out of the kitchen and that's
where he's going because it's like is he
just leaving or is he also going to be
bringing foggy and Karen what's the
question is like do we have those yeah
Tommy's just making noises what if what
if what if episode one of Daredevil is
him breaking up with Jen we're gonna be
also devastated we're all gonna be so
sad
I don't know so I mean but if he starts
on the west coast he's like listen I'm
Daredevil you're She-Hulk it just can't
work out in this world make it a Twist
that make it more hopeful maybe he
leaves Hell's Kitchen to be oh and uh oh
so the thing is someone in this town
doesn't work that way someone in the
chat says imagine going from morning
into that it's uh just a filming title
they always film under another title
that way people walking down the street
don't go like oh born again and like
walk over to set if this is just like
literally what's on the clapboard don't
don't assume that's what it's called
because of the filming type when I
worked at uh Bob's Burgers when they
were coming out of the movie it was
called Jazzy jazz hands that was what
the movie was called because we couldn't
actively be like Bob's Burgers the movie
like we had to be like Jesse Jackson
sisters
no I love them they're my favorite I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding guys Kate
Blanchett will be returning to what as
hella for season two of what if that's
bock bock why is that so I don't know is
that a confirmed I think it's been
confirmed it was it was actually a news
yesterday that was unconfirmed
um but that's exciting I meant it I
would do it also yeah I don't want
anyone else playing hella uh John
barenthal's trainer is hinting at the
punisher's return let me look at this
photo real quick look at this Instagram
photo uh I've been with this Jack
trainer and at the very end the caption
says can't wait to work with you during
Marvel phase five that's not even a hit
no that's not even a hint I love two
things about that photo one that his
trainer looks like someone from Hell's
Kitchen yeah like looks like a jacked
like crime either I I don't know which
side of crime he's on and then the John
Bernthal looks like he just heard it got
leaked in that photo yeah if it's just
like bro the thing is
that's that's like John Bertha always
has like resting badass face but there's
a little contemplative oh no in that one
also his trainer is
like post-workout and John is John's
like I'm in his shirt bro dude leave me
out of this I I it's not a Punisher pump
it's yeah that's true it's also
I mean it's not a hit saying that unless
you do know something but it could be
him like being like hey Marvel hire me
as my man
I'm gonna get him punished shred I I ran
into him at a at an event a little while
ago and I listened to his podcast like
that his really incredible podcast
called real ones where he talks to like
real life people that have seen some
[ __ ] and uh he was so excited to talk
about Punisher but so aware that
anything he said would be inferred as
anything else so I can't imagine like
just people running up until the time
and then his trainer of all people's
like by the way like he gets away with I
just feel bad for anyone in Marvel
anything they do any photo they take
anything they like well John those
assumes because of that podcast well not
a lot of other good podcasts but like he
seems like a person that is like John
Cena where it's like yeah I have a huge
fan base and I recognize my fan base and
he does like take pictures and actively
is like yeah come over here yeah no no
he likes to engage like and he also
works yeah you guys love John he's the
best of both line I love him we love you
John I love him I'm taking this headline
okay go ahead it's emotional for me is
it camera three don't cry Westworld
has died HBO has canceled Westworld
there'll be no fifth season it'll end on
the fourth season God knows it didn't
end with a concrete they didn't land the
plane who knows what's gonna happen in
Westworld 34 Emmy nominations eight wins
including Tandy Newton's winning for
best supporting actress in 2019 18 where
she said I don't believe in God but I
think I should thank him now all time
except in speech moment uh yeah I have a
prediction because we know that uh uh
Jonah Jonathan Nolan and Lisa Joy who
are a married uh creative team can you I
mean talk about asking where you eat
right come on everybody they're messing
all over each other then making a meal
out of it uh they're doing peripheral
which by the way for those of you that
followed along the new Rockstar's uh
Twitter feed I did a live stream for the
first two episodes it's a great show
that show is going to get more seasons I
predict so they're probably moving on
anyway but here's what I think they're
going to land Westworld with a nice
two-hour movie for us we're gonna get a
movie
this is all part of uh uh David's Zazzle
last David Zazzle zazlov he's thinning
things down right like Westworld had a
huge huge budget huge it took forever to
film it was kind of made sense the the
you know they're not abandoning their
original series Euphoria will move on uh
there's there's a bunch of other titles
that they announced we'll continue
moving on but Westworld kind of is
illogical let's end it season four
giving a movie to kind I think I mean
they haven't announced the movie I
predict there will be a at least one
movie set in the world of Westworld
weren't they uh they were like prepared
or they were I don't even think they
were prepared but they were like oh
hopeful for a fifth season so we can
wrap this up and then it's just like
yeah I do think like there is there
there are scenarios with some of these
like really high concept difficult uh
World built shows to kind of uh what's
the right word compact the season into
one kind of two two-hour story to end it
you know like we don't necessarily need
another because westbound has blown out
so much from the first season took place
in the theme park now it's in the world
where like synthesoids are like you know
uh uh whatever uh AI are now like
interacting with humans and are unable
you can't decipher who's a human who's
an AI so yeah just give us a movie sew
it up sew it up baby speaking of sewing
it up
we go to a lot of conventions okay and
we sew up cute little costumes okay and
when we go there we love getting the
swag but let's be honest a lot of the
swag is kind of stinky it's a little
doodoo swag and if you've got that
doodoo swag you know my boy grab swag
and you know our album The Dump has just
dropped on stink records damn how do I
get in that it's cheap it doesn't fit it
definitely doesn't make us want to
support the business well our friends at
Lands End Business
they're putting it into the scourge of
bad swag once and for all get fully
customized clothes accessories and
promotional products featuring your logo
and colors elevated by Decades of
experience imagine a beautiful break
room vest or or a headband that says the
break room or Gucci to moochie on it see
your logo in Vivid colors on t-shirts
outerwear hats mugs water bottles and
more hundreds of products perfect for
any trade show event or holiday gift I
always say you hear that back there
start making Christmas presents or
holiday presents whatever you celebrate
see why thousands of companies count on
Lands End Business go to business dot
lands end.com slash podcast and use your
promo code podcast for 25 off your first
product that's business.com Lands End
I'm sorry
business.landsend.com podcast it's right
there on the screen just screen grab it
promo code podcast for 25 off your first
product the promo code is what
podcast
you guys it's time for our discussion
which I don't think we've seen this in a
long time Joshua can you do your break
room breakdown
[Music]
oh
I don't know if you guys remember that
used to be my graphic now we just have
discussions we'll call it break room
discussions that's because we don't like
breaking down anything else on our
Channel break room is its own thing yeah
it's already it's the room of a break
it's already broken look here I want to
get to my lunch as quick as possible so
we need to go through it let's go in a
new interview with extra Henry Cavill
said this about the Betrayal of Superman
he said it's just a pleasure to be back
to be honest and I'm so excited to dig
further into this character and to
explore this character some more and
make that make and make that I give the
audience and make oh money give the
audience everything that they deserve
for sure that I give y'all ah the word
sure is missing I don't think he said it
I think he just said and make that and
make that I'll give the order yes he's
English I can hear it oh is he English
yeah I'm an idiot uh this off the backs
of a new earnings call you are
let's go
I'm just kidding who's my smart little
girl so much Friday interview it's pure
Friday so this off the backs of a new
earnings call where the new WB Chief
David zazlov doubled down on their
commitment to franchise theatrical
releases saying we haven't had a
Superman movie in 13 years oh my God
that's how he said it I do love a good
earnings call guys the most exciting two
hours in entertainment I got a theory
about that 13 years thing yeah there's
no math that makes sense then
well no 13 years ago was not even yeah
Superman was 2006 with uh returns yeah
and then this was 2000 I believe 13.
yeah so maybe he's accidentally
inferring it's gonna be 13 years between
them and we get one in 2026.
[Applause]
wasn't it well look it up checking the
tapes that big ass phone also I just
wanted to come 2013. so what if he's
accidentally saying like that's too far
well if they film it right now 2026 for
years
till 2023. back in my day you filmed a
movie it came out the next week
what version of the character will we
get in the future of the DC films uh he
wore his Man of Steel costume in Black
Adam post credit scene but ended the
Justice League Snyder cut in his black
suit will this be a half reboot of the
character or do you think that they'll
just try to continue the cast members
like Amy Adams Diane Lane and Jesse
Eisenberg I think we're going back to
the Blue Man of Steel suit I think I
think all Snyder related properties are
going to be like thank you for your time
here it is now over I know that he did
Man of Steel that is technically a
Snyder related property didn't
Christopher Nolan do a draft of Man of
Steel he produced and also there was an
idea of having him do it they wanted him
to they're recording him after Dark
Knight foreign
for that origin I'm not trying to take
any credit away from Zack Snyder I
enjoyed Man of Steel as a film but I
just think the Justice League Snyder cut
I think DC is going to be and and Warner
is going to be very clear that like we
did that for you guys that was it for
the fans thing and for Zach and for
Zach's you know Legion of fans that
think that that he's can do no wrong and
and deserve to have that cut come out
and maybe then they may be right so
that's out but that's not where this is
moving I wouldn't be surprised if this
movie is a direct sequel to Man of Steel
kind of the way they did tournament they
tried to do with Terminator where they
were like this movie is a sequel to
Terminator 2 and all of the Terminators
and Superman Returns even Brandon Ralph
was the same reason
a while ago Warner Brothers was like
when the whole Justice League Snyder cut
thing was happening and Jack Snyder was
like I'm gonna go in there take my
footage and leave with it and they were
like we aren't going in that direction
we're going into a different direction
you think they're just gonna completely
jump that and not acknowledge it
whatsoever because how is that gonna
happen with like the flash I think flash
I think the reason the Flash movie is
coming out even with someone that's
potentially facing 26 years is because
it resets everything like I think it's
too important to what the DCU is about
to be I think the end of flash literally
allows for all this Clean Slate so
because Flashpoint you can change
continuity so I think the way we get
bats like when we want him or not the
way we get Keaton sometimes is how flash
ends I think that's literally the Crux
of the entire future of DC otherwise I
don't I don't think they'd make sure it
comes out like because there's been
nothing but bad press yeah exactly so I
feel like flash is the way all this
resets I think we're gonna have a
optimistic joyful he keeps talking about
how happy this new Superman is I think
it's going to be a very Christopher
Reeve classic very like stand up Jeff
Loeb Superman like so I'm into it that's
Superman yeah yeah that's the character
my second question of how would we feel
about Superman going in the direction of
the Joker and the Batman movies see I
what I love about Batman is that he's
the one that we identify with around the
Gods like Batman is is even though he's
a billionaire he's the most approachable
billionaire like he's our eye line so
Joker is the the Batman is our every man
in the world and he's the guy that's
fighting with sheer willpower Joker is
all chaos to Batman's rules they're
inherently separate from everything even
if they're in the Justice League those
characters shouldn't have to play in the
same sandbox so I don't think Superman
should tie into what Pattinson did I
think they should keep a grounded Batman
over here and then have a Justice League
Batman with this Superman okay I
completely agree really quick because
I've been getting a lot of people in our
chat uh our Redemption today is if we
break to 100 we'll spend some extra time
doing kind of an AMA and we'll answer
any questions you guys have guys have to
an extent make them appropriate because
I will Overlook them if they're not
appropriate yeah Mama's here mama
Clemens is here and she's not having it
no I just want to clarify with this
question are we talking about
stylistically like the style of the
Joker and the new Batman movie or are we
just I think that's an independent
character more so like is because I I
think it's more framing this question
there Matt Reeves is Batman or Matt
Reeves is the Batman is going to go on
for a very long time it's going to go on
for a very long time and the Joker
already got it second so it's like do we
want a character that's not in the same
universe as the flash as Jason Momo was
Aquaman as Galaxy Black Label is a very
successful imprint of DC they're
literally different sized Comics have
your Batman have your Joker that you
want to be all rated separate and then
have a shared Universe like that I would
not I wouldn't have Robert Pattinson's
Batman have a single thing to do with
whatever Batman's in the D in the
Justice League you want so you okay so I
guess this is an overall question for
everybody here you want a Superman movie
that is completely separate from
everyone else no no to start yes but I
want that Superman iteration to be
involved with the Justice League going
forward like however yeah so like you
can have him like acknowledge the world
well then how are they gonna reboot it
is
but and they're trying to make sure that
they don't follow the same suit as all
the manisters exactly
hard oh well that's why they got the two
best to do it like Peter saffron is one
of the great creative producers he's
he's on Hands-On for Aquaman it made a
billion dollars he's Hands-On for Shazam
an unknown character not a lot of people
got which led to Black Adam all these
things and then you've got James Gunn
who is one of the biggest comic Geeks in
the world one of the best directors
working in that lore and is a showman
like Kevin feige so you've literally got
the two best people to possibly
spearhead this very hard 10-headed
Dragon to take out I like that I I uh I
think it begins and ends with mixelpicks
it always has Mr mixlepicks you got to
say his name backwards to make him
disappear wait what you don't know what
Mr Mrs is
he's a bad guy in uh Superman and Batman
comics he's a little like uh he's right
his little floaty bold guys he comes
from a different dimension and the only
way to get him to go back to his
Dimension is if you say his name
backwards how do you say it backwards
okay so we never he's never going I mean
it's hard to read yeah
what I would do for the Superman movie
to come back is right now we need a
Superman that believes in Hope and and
like positivity to show that's the way
they're going right so the thing
Superman can't do is save everyone the
beautiful conflict of Superman is that
he's so powerful he can't possibly be
everywhere at once I would have Brainiac
come in because that's a thinking
villain that's going to be able to
manipulate what that earnesty of
Superman is and we haven't seen him yet
but that could also lead to that being a
Justice League level threat I like it's
so
it and this could just be me you guys I
recognize what I'm saying you're gonna
have to do a lot for me to get back into
Superman like you're gonna have to do a
lot to get me back into something guys
show your worth okay Jessica's not just
gonna go to your movie just because it's
called Superman you're gonna have to do
a lot to get her back into it would you
stylistic
how Joker did something completely
different than they've ever done with
Joker would you be interested in that
for Superman
what if they just made a movie what if
they just made a movie called Clark and
it's just about a guy trying to beat a
deadline for an article like he's like I
scooped this thing where this restaurant
is poisoning its workers and I gotta get
this article on The Daily Planet before
Monday and then Perry White's like Clark
we can't run the story you don't have
the information and he has to prove it
and there's never any Superman in it
except for at one point there's like a
car about to hit Lois Lane and Clark
just stops it with his hand but she
doesn't notice kind of like Twilight and
that's the whole movie would that get
you back into it yeah great that's it I
do think I had the same problem when I
was making plug my 1 Wonder Woman music
video and like making an original song
when I was making plug my new music
video no I swear it does tie in
for Wonder Woman that the song would be
based around was difficult because when
you take a character that's built on
like self-assurance knowing that you're
doing the right thing you know like sort
of like a very clean image it's hard to
find the conflict in there that's going
to be interesting to audience it's also
right Batman is popular right now
because like we're cynical right Batman
represents like I need to beat this
problem down oh I Believe In Hope
because I realize that's not enough the
ending of the Batman's perfect because
it's him realizing just violence isn't
the answer but you have to go through
the cynicism of 2020 to get there I
think the thing with Superman is when
Christopher Reeve was Superman in the
70s we weren't as cynical because we
weren't as exposed to each other like
the internet has made us all see all of
the flaws in humanity which can unify us
long term but right now the internet's
so new we're our our gray matter isn't
formatted for what we're consuming I
don't think the internet makes our you
see all the flaws in humanity I'm just
kidding
that's because everybody argues about
everything yeah Murphy's gonna look away
and be like oh my God
right like I think the internet's a
great place to express yourself and
ideas I think Superman isn't of this
world so they have to write around that
do you think we'll see Superman becoming
very cynical no we have to that's what
we we had he killed we need a Superman
that's better than us we need to show
that someone can be idealistic and not
be cheesy we need something that's that
Pitch Perfect tone almost like Captain
America like what Chris Evans did he
improved on the character of Captain
America like his cap is better than the
comics in my opinion because you believe
in his Earnest patriotism and he's not
blindly patriotic like the characters
sometimes like when her Soldier was able
to show like he wants the American
people even if it betrays the systems we
need a Superman that's able to convey
that we can all believe in something
bigger than us better than us we can
have hope we can have this thing but
right now the world isn't capable of
that so this movie has to be better than
we are yeah but good good luck Good Luck
Good Godspeed making that interesting I
don't know right that's like you were
saying yeah plug plug
it's all at the end of the day it's
plugged so we know Joker 2 is filming
Warner Brother is also looking towards
they want to make more Harry Potter
movies real burn to the Fantastic Beasts
franchise during the the call when he
was like we've made a Harry Potter movie
in 20 years or whatever 15 years it's
like yeah you've made three fantastic
Beast movies that very few people have
you know last not too too hard uh but
they want to make them with Harry Potter
himself which they said will involve a
conversation with uh JK Rowling which
you know should be really fun and then
they want to make more Lord of the Rings
movies which is kind of confusing
because Amazon just spent a billion
dollars making a Lord of the Rings
series so I guess it's kind of like what
franchises do we think the Warner
Brothers has could we turn into two uh
trilogies as aslav seems to want to
double down on making these franchise
movies guys I need them to just uh put
their money where their freaking mouths
are I can curse now through 30 [ __ ]
mouth socks swear give me give me some
more static shock and I've been waiting
I've been counting the days uh honestly
any black superhero but uh I'm doubling
down on static shock I would love to see
static shock again I I would like to see
I know this is gonna okay actually I'm
gonna take it back this is what I was
gonna say and then I'm gonna say why I
disagree with myself I would like them
to give Tim Burton an opportunity to
make an original thing again that is not
an adaptation of some Gothic literature
or French or movie or or something that
he can like put his own little dark
world spin on but then I remember that
Tim bird only cast white people people
in his movies and I'm sorry I love Tim
Burton but like until he learns how to
cast a more diverse crew and and have a
more diverse experience [ __ ] him he
doesn't get a Trilogy in mind I love
Tommy told that's all I gotta say I love
Tim Burton I have three Tim Burton books
with growing up but he was a hero of
mine but as I get older I can't help but
think if you don't know how to cast
things other than what you look at in
the mirror you probably shouldn't be
casting I love it
you've already been in love let's not
pretend I'm not the black king of this
show why would you
I believe Anna did not say that I
purposefully turned away when you were
doing your black king [ __ ] I have to be
out my black king [ __ ] I was labeled the
black king okay it's not a it's not a
guy grew up claiming it I was Crown I
was crowned by you don't you bring me
into this you crowned me you made me
this man I'm trying so hard please what
are you uncomfortable I'm the one that
has to wear the crown oh my God oh my
God heavy is the head that where's the
crown
I'm so sorry Anna I'm so sorry your king
is arrived
we're just having it like it's just it's
just occurring oh my God oh my
anti-cancellation
time is it not not this camera Dash will
stop it your king cannot be canceled
yeah all right good point good point Tim
Burton didn't make Wednesday with
Hispanic leads and speaking of JK
Rowling's good choices and and kings
everyone nope please yep thank you
everyone at new rock stars is a Ally to
the lgbtq plus Community qia plus
Community the [ __ ] does that have to do
with anything community we all love
everyone okay excuse me
I don't know this person all right back
on me please what are we talking about
more franchises okay so Anna wants
Scooby-Doo with Lisa oh Lisa Linda
Lucifer I love Linda Cardellini and
Matthew Lillard bring back Matthew
yeah
scary I would like written by James Gunn
who's running DC there it is he's right
there he would be like he could produce
Scooby-Doo though
this made this work what'd you say
yeah yeah so James Gunn already ready to
run that franchise overseas so uh I want
Lethal Weapon uh I am a devout Lethal
Weapon fan yes even the sitcom was uh
sitcom was great so surprised apart
because Damon Wayans I think one had bad
health and then yeah
but a little bit difficult yeah Clayton
and Damon didn't seem to get along but
uh Lethal Weapon is a genre we don't get
a lot of buddy cop is timeless if you
look at like the nice guys which didn't
get enough love if you look at like the
buddy cop movies we occasionally get
they're not marketing Soldier they're
just marketed well right so have the
Lethal Weapon weapon uh weapon franchise
come back but maybe a little less
compaganda like you could make you could
make it a little more interesting for
the Everyman and I'd love to see a cop
on the edge with a little more Nuance
that was a propaganda era in the 80s and
90s propaganda and Copacabana you know
what
Brandon all Lethal Weapon movies are all
four of them are perfect
brought us Jet Lee Chris Rock the third
one we got the Allison revoked
diplomatic immunity
is that a good idea I don't know you
tell me are you the producer of the show
what makes it easy to drink all my daily
nutrition in one easy and tasty drink
I'll tell you what ag-1 and athletic
greens each scoop of ag-1 has 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and other good
stuff you need to stay on top of your
game ag1 is one thing you can do every
single day to take great care of
yourself your king commands it reclaim
your house and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition it's
just one scoop of a cup of water every
day that's it I like to shake it I do a
little dance I put some music on by the
end the ag1 is liquefied baby it's so
good and to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase now as koi and I can tell
you vitamin D is essential to the fair
skin gentleness we're not going to get
it from the Sun as the sun is trying to
kill us at all times all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com breakroom
again that is that that is
athleticgreens.com break room break room
is the code that helps us and helps you
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance and I'll say ag1 is the
sponsor that I use like every day and I
legit use it it's nice it's been so nice
having them as a sponsor up until this
episode
yep that's uh hopefully it continues on
forever all right we want to shout out
to I think you know I think you guys got
to just lean into the flow of the Friday
episode stop letting it scare you we
want to shout out the second season of a
very scary good hit show DC's Batman the
audio Adventures which is out now on HBO
Max it's got an awesome cast that
includes Rosario Dawson John Leguizamo
and Bobby Moynihan Jeffrey Wright who
played Jim Gordon in the Batman is
voicing the Caped Crusader himself in
this show as I said yesterday what a
glow up this guy is one of the best
voices working in the biz today you
better believe it that's enough Arnold
that's from Westworld now canceled the
shows the show follows Batman as he
navigates a crime-infested Gotham with
harleen quinzel Catwoman The Riddler cat
women
fat women Ah that's just what I call my
unmarried aunts The Riddler and all the
other Rogues Gallery we love the show
was created by long time SNL writer
Dennis mcnicholas Jolly Old mcnicholas
writing his Batman he stacked that cast
with some comedy ringer it's like Bobby
moyna and Chris Barnell Keenan Thompson
and John leg was ammo tune in for the
tale of life and death in Gotham City
also the Monahan lime was right there
I'm going to hand it right it was
perfect the whole season one is already
in available to stream and season two is
out now on HBO Max stream DC's Batman
the audio Adventures season two now on
HBO Max it's time for mandatory fun
we have no way of keeping track of how
much Super we did it oh okay I feel like
we got to be easily over or at least
must be close enough close enough close
enough but let's do mandatory fun first
then the AMA must begin and you can ask
any of your cute little questions John's
getting in there now oh he's putting a
total in I can't wait all right listen
mandatory fun this is where I gather
three oh we're at 196. never mind we're
not there yet guys sorry
3.83 to go sorry we're not gonna get
there we're there all right listen
this is mandatory fun the segment is so
spicy we play this segment twice see the
graphic twice he hit it again yes my
queen you can always win a crown you
wear the crown every day thank you in my
mind the crown of my mind the crown of
my teeth whoa you got crowns on your
teeth we'll get into it later
all right now
come for my teammates I will never your
teeth are perfect that's what I wouldn't
choose in the back I have
jack-o'-lantern teeth I won't come for
anybody's teeth look at these things
okay Cory let's see yours
you guys all three of you have beautiful
smiles and I have a smile that mothers
could love all right now
mandatory fun is when I gather my three
best friends together and we have some
fun good old Quentin Tarantino gave us a
dynamite quote about why he'll never
directing our Marvel or DC film saying
you have to be a hard hand to do those
things Tarantino is not Irish uh he
could be you Tarantino uh he went on to
say I'm not a Hired Hand I'm not looking
for a job what are you me talking to my
dad when you're 16. come on Tarantino we
call [ __ ] so now we're gonna pitch
some movies that we think Tarantino
could do in the superhero world and I I
had asked you guys before to come
prepared so hopefully you are koi I know
that you did confirm that you were
prepared ready all right what do you got
for us okay when you think of Tarantino
you think of three things yes think of
uh intense language yes you think of uh
lots and lots of bloodletting creatively
ways with montages you think of feet
yeah all right so in this world I'm like
what character has verbose language uses
a hook as his weapon for great violence
and bloodletting actually has a foot
fetish low bump
a lobo movie in the DC Universe James
Gunn would let it be rated R we've
already got the established setup
Tarantino is going to want to play in
his own wheelhouse not share a universe
Lobo doesn't need to go in the greater
DC Universe Lobo can be a cosmic space
Hunter a la what Deadpool could be for
DC you let it be kinky you let it be fun
you let him have some space sex and you
let it be R-rated violent and bloody
with a hook all sorts of good times can
be had by all I mean aliens space sex
space no one can hear you crying
so were you guys on that level I said
sounds with him oh that's way yeah no I
was trying to do PG-13 these are crazy I
mean I respect it we don't know if those
technical screen we don't have the toes
cream it's space toast yeah they're
aliens who knows how what like organs
you got okay mine's not as disgusting
okay can I do do you want to go no no no
I want you vote are you choosing who
wins all right well you're all winners
in my eyes but please go okay so mine is
and this is for like deep Quentin
Tarantino people because I don't I think
he was more like a producer on this but
either way have you seen Death Proof one
of your favorite movies of all time
where it has four women that kick ass
and beat the hell out of this man that's
trying to kill them in a car I want the
same thing done but I want it for
Hellcat and I would love for Hellcat to
be honest team with She-Hulk and I would
love them to just get other two women we
can choose any women I would okay maybe
Rogue maybe throw Rogue in there I'd
want some from the X-Men and some from
here and I'd want them to just be four
years
Department we are destroying this person
so I want a Death Proof version of like
Marvel women just killing and it could
still be wasn't it car Russell is it
Russell yeah
he's not man Mike is he good loving
Planet it's great yes it works
Intergalactic Planet Chase I want
Hellcat to be the blonde one that's the
stuff that's actually the stun right
actually if any Tito's known for
anything it's remaking so there it is is
that her name yes yes yes yes he's
finally self-masperator enough to remake
his own film but in Marvel yes there you
go okay Anna what do you got for us when
you think of Quentin Tarantino you think
of three things you think of the Muppets
Wizard of Oz you think of little Mickey
and you think of how Tastefully he
handled the subject matter in Django
Unchained now I say we come I feel like
you just Googled this
oh my God he was in Little Nicky that's
right yeah he was the craziest we
combined all these we get a comedic
Muppets version of black panther
what is this wait I'm the problem wait
wait a minute I'm sorry our black
Queen's here oh my God Crown her ass
it's crazy because it's not me
that's insane
you know what sometimes you you either
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain she did not
see that coming heat off me heat on the
end Meister now I'll go last uh that's
Greenland immediately of course and by
Greenland I mean we're gonna burn it
I've never talk about it again it might
have been the funniest
my film goes into the world of comics
but not in the world of Marvel or DC
mine goes into the world of Eastman
Kevin Eastman specifically Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles but we're not
focusing on these Turtles no we're
focusing on the Foot Clan uh the movie
is simply called The Foot Clan it is two
hours of uh martial arts guys and gals
only the fronts of their feet kicking so
it's a lot of kiosks and if he close up
with like some cool sound effects and
then in the last minute of the movie uh
the turtles come in and they go you guys
want to fight and they just get kicked
to death by feet and then uh that's it
that's perfect
uh we're all winners today but more
importantly the chat has won the Super
Chat challenge so let's answer some of
these super chat questions let's just go
down in order what do we got here thank
you thank you by the way to everyone oh
yes now let's do one each we'll go down
and you can do the first one okay that I
can't stop
I think you took the spot
can be Peter Walter and the MCU Walter
was in the boys no question there do we
keep it up here I can't stop
very relatable who would be your Godly
parent like very fairly fairy god oh I
thought it was like ego I'm a good guy
um I would choose Anna Anna's a good
Godparent John Bernthal [ __ ] up John
Burnham tells my God hair in what way uh
John barenthal sorry why are we sorry
what's your Fairy Godparent you looked
at me like Jessica oh no no no no no no
uh my Godparent would be
um
this is so tough because I feel such a
connection to Christ and God uh I think
it would have to be uh the my pillow guy
I like I like the way that he makes his
own movies I like that he's a
self-starter I like that he's a former
crack addict and I like his pillows who
the my pillow guy I don't know who this
is oh he's a horrible
horrible man uh I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say uh Ron Popeil the guy from The
infomercials that makes those rotisserie
chickens I'm perfect
I said redheads are more kinky just
saying I said John Bird though but yeah
he'd protect me I like respect him God
bless sure
um might choke you out Tasha Tasha
Tommy's Tasha Tasha yes love you Tasha
you can also be my Tasha Tasha but Tommy
is always where was Tommy on January 6th
watching TV horrified horrified that
they weren't letting those Patriots do
what they wanted
okay well here I know you don't get the
Hat this whole episode
I'm not slipping up my feet are planted
on the ground
did anyone else uh love Fringe and could
you see any cast members coming to the
MCU you know what I need to watch is
fringe available for streaming somewhere
because I gotta watch the show everybody
says it's good I think George takei's in
a few episodes I gotta watch my boy
Charlie from Mighty Ducks is on it
Joshua Jackson he's married to Jody
Turner Smith hello power couple
uh let us know if it's streaming I guess
that was the question yeah why do you
got it why you gotta say it like that
they I asked him nicely come on it's
your turn okay my question take my money
I will next one thank you Christian
unpronounceable by the way can we turn
them into class questions if they're not
questions it'll be a fun time thank you
for a girl for for sending us a Super
Chat put everyone in DC on their own
Earth and bring them together and a
crisis on infinite Earths and then said
hi to all of us and we say hi to you
figure we love you thank you Clayton
thank you Brian K for always supporting
Jay right melee send twenty dollars I
got paid super grateful to you badass
rock stars we are super grateful to you
GSU Eagle 117 always coming in and uh
what video game is everyone currently
playing
um is there
a
um a new Witcher game out
no no okay and you know if you're
playing it no no no I'm sorry I should
have clarified I am not currently
playing any games right now I have
outdated systems I I need to get on
board with the future and my switch is
at my mommy's house so I'm hopefully be
getting that back soon I let my nephews
play with it because I'm that kind of
guy but uh my friends are playing a game
I thought they were saying it was like a
new version of The Witcher but my nephew
plays a lot of GTA online he's a big
into GTA online he loves the blackjack
tables at the casino we're real proud of
him uh
I recently played for Halloween I played
a game called milk inside of a bag of
milk inside of a bag of milk which was
very interesting psychological horror uh
check it out the second one gets it is a
trigger warning just so you know
um I'm also about to play House Of Ashes
which is part of the dark Anthology
series
um I I know I've the rest are better I
think I think House Of Ashes is known to
be a little bit one of the weaker ones
but I'm excited for that Danganronpa
three if we have any really deep
cuttings are we doing like six games
what are you playing right now I play
Valerian League of Legends any game you
guys want to play with me online My name
is uh writing Shrek or writing Shrek
that's my name
but I also wag mom if you want to play a
crazy game like Anna's game um it's
called Uh uh
where's my baby and you have to chase
Your Baby around a house and catch it
but the baby can do everything what is
that the one with it with a little it's
like a demon baby no it can't but the
thing is it gets into things and it gets
into like the cleaning closet you have
to get to it in time what was the scary
game you made me play all those years
ago oh my God it wasn't phasmaphobia yes
don't play that game if you don't like
being scared so I'm not too scared I
monetized all my hobbies so I only play
games not online and I'm playing games
from like five years ago because I'm way
behind but I'm finally just starting the
Miles Morales Spider-Man game which is
oh hell yeah hell yeah
classic because I love the soundtrack
and it reminds me of when things were
innocent and free the Wipeout games were
the Wipeout racing games those anti-grab
racer cars playing Wipeout Excel and
Miles Morales because YouTube have you
you I know you have have you ever played
Snake King the Burger King video game
there's a Burger King video games
but what about the KFC Dating Game yes I
did and I streamed it I streamed it and
it's so fun it's such a fun storytelling
game please play you should stream it
it's so fun it's so fun and Colonel
Sanders is so hot plug
all right next let's get to some more
questions here Clemens sorry Clemens
sorry Clement sorry you've got three h
Tom we're glad to have you here hot take
I would like to see a bit more letters
that is a smoldering hot take does that
count as my question because I hope it
doesn't okay I'm gonna say no I'm a no
thank you I'm a I'm a pastor
respectfully pass uh 1300 watching 262
likes like the stream people I agree
with that's not a question uh Daredevil
leader of the flyover states Avengers
yeah uh that's funny Daredevil Nebraska
I'm just excited for when Disney plus
releases the baby Groot versus baby Yoda
special oh it's like like in Pokemon the
first movie when the Pikachus were like
slapping each other and crying it's
coming now it's cute you guys you guys
are too young out of the kitchen
for a dream uh baby frogs bro Google
there it is snoke after dark that's
Tommy's podcast uh Anna how you doing um
mine's called King [ __ ]
pretty good day
I'm good thank you how are you I'm
turning 23 Tuesday I have two questions
for you guys do you think we'll see
Hulk's other son hero kala since we saw
Scar and do you think we'll see Cal
quesis in live action if so what future
project I do think we'll see calcasus is
mine sir uh also Hulk I get it there's
no condom that can contain the Hulk but
come on man
how many kids there's no condom that can
contain the hole no
can stretch to a very large degree yeah
but like what would it be made out of
water
mine are stainless steel
regular balloon
guys it's Friday and here we are at the
end of the show we've got another six
minutes
I love you I love your face brother Beck
told you Capri to go on Hollywood is
listening uh Austin long said here's ten
dollars because you guys are awesome as
hell love you guys from the slopper to
the squirters
squirter oh I like that that's still mid
though Jubilee is still mid though
Brandon don't listen to those men and
women Jubilee is
my favorite one uh great way to end a
week thank y'all as always for making me
laugh guys we appreciate all of you
thank you for hanging out with us today
on the break room I think that's it I'm
exhausted
what an episode you guys
there was we got to get you in the
producer Booth you got a lot of great
ideas for the vision
you've got a great Direction I agree uh
Jets versus Buffalo running the show now
because of [ __ ] like that also someone
said Jessica can I eat half your seafood
boil absolutely come on down yeah
there's one shrimp Winnipeg oh is is Cal
the guy Cameron Monahan plays the record
oh I'd like to see more of him because
he's played by Cameron Brandon stop your
slander I am the second black queen to
Anna uh you guys thanks for joining you
know what you're doing it right now and
it's mischievous please like And
subscribe guys we need you thank you for
all the super chats this week we'll be
back next week with a whole new slate of
nerd news we got you know all of our
friends will be back hopefully these
friends will rejoin us it's the break
room is an Empire that cannot be stopped
the Sun never sets on the break room
Empire we love you very much good day
foreign
[Music]